pray and at 5:00 in the morning this
goes on if when I'm right now I didn't
do that for the first phrase to fight
novice at first Norton fight really no
sir
our head got big and I started thinking
it was my training camp at my boxing
ability they kept me where I was that
and God punished me and he gave me a
good whooping he broke my jaw in the
sacrum fight and he got me whooped and
knocked down in the Fraser fighting I
realized I wasn't that great after all
so I had to get not only together
physically but spiritually for this
fight I've trained every day for five
days five times a day for the past four
months and everything is perfect and if
I lost with me it ain't no way no man
can win no man I feel I got something I
can definitely relate to you know in a
lot of ways you know I was I was
undefeated I remember I was on the
future also and before that fight where
I told my CL I came back I was praying I
didn't that I did every prayer every day
went to mosques a night and then I
remember before my last fight - I kind
of got away from me and I kind of
questioned it sometimes but it is I know
it's not good and just just hearing him
say that now it's like oh my god maybe
just woke me up a little bit I do think
differently now about a lot of things
you know priority wise and life wise
spirituality wise so I definitely relate
to him in a lot of ways besides be
Muslim just as mentally yeah and just
how proud he is and in it is gives you
hope you see the confidence when God is
with you there's no man that can stop
you right and he was missing that he
talks about how he got his jaw broke he
thought it was my training camp there's
me and me and you see many of these many
fighters you see for many of them though
the beat they'll pump the chest and it's
like it's all and that spiritual
component for many people is it's huge